I mean they've gone so far CNN a
reporter on CNN Sara Sidner national
correspondents openly defended and maids
excuses on national television for the
rioters I know people see violence and
think that people are just taking
advantage of the situation and there may
be some people who are I don't know that
every single person is doing this born
out of pain but I can tell you many
people are we've seen it they don't know
what to do with that emotion so their
response especially young folks is to
lash out and one of the young folks we
talked to him on your show you had him
on your show a young man who is from
Minneapolis who said do you see all this
damage here you don't listen to us when
we speak so you listen to us now don't
you so acting out gets attention and
they know that because the other way
hasn't gotten them the attention it
hasn't done anything it hasn't changed
anything so they're hoping this will
will it I don't know I was in Ferguson
in 2014 for three months we're back here
again
same scenario just about there wasn't a
gun involved there was a knee involved
acting out gets them attention I almost
don't even want to address all the
stupid factually incorrect things she
said like she's still perpetuating this
lie that Michael Brown in Ferguson was
shot with his hands up saying don't
shoot didn't happen multiple Topsy's
showed the guy Michael Brent reached for
the cops gun the gun went off in the cop
car many many eyewitnesses all saying
the same thing she's just perpetuating
that lie she's perpetuating this lie
that there was some justification for
the riots here I I don't even want to
get into it I just want to get into this
really dumb bit of political philosophy
really dumb bit of parenting
she said acting out gets attention yeah
that's true everyone who's ever met a
teenager knows everyone has ever met a
toddler knows that acting out gets
attention but when you want to raise a
good child you don't give them attention
when they do bad things because that
will reinforce the bad behavior that
will incentivize the bad behavior
you know what happens then you get more
of it but we don't know that we don't
know that anymore in our culture we
don't know how to raise another
generation that's why things have
spiraled so far out of control there's a
connection here between the breakdown of
the family and the breakdown of civil
society people have been predicting this
for many years it's not just about
orange man bad I know you want to blame
all your troubles if you're on the left
on President Trump but it's not
President Trump and even if it were
president from America elected president
Trump the trouble about a representative
democracy is you get representatives and
representatives are representative of
you the voters I think the president
Trump is actually offering a little bit
of hope to try to get back to something
that we've lost and I think that that
longing is why people elected him in the
first place to restore some law and
order to restore a sense of justice but
you can't be in a situation where you're
indulging all of this terrible behavior
there is no justification for rioting
these are not genuinely wounded people
who just want to be heard weapon oh
they're degenerate criminals who are
stealing people's property and killing
people and setting buildings on fire
there it's not compassionate to anybody
to be nice to criminals you remember we
saw that video of the woman in
Minneapolis sobbing because her
neighborhood had been burned down and
all the stores that she goes to have
been burned down all the places she
frequents burned down it's not
compassionate to her to be nice to
derelict criminals who should be rotting
in prison for a very long time
[Music]
you
[Music]